hi everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Washington tonight
humiliating themselves that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
oh they're so excited they just can't
hide it they're almost glowing waiting
for their bundle of joy arriving now in
March
Donald Trump already has a very packed
legal calendar you may have heard it
does another proposed trial date is now
filling up Trump's calendar right in the
thick of the GOP primaries in March in
fact the date finally Willis has
proposed is the day before super Tuesday
how do you think this is going over for
the former president and his team right
now that could force him to lose a very
critical election window ahead of you
know actually determining who the
nominee is a March 4th trial date for
the disgraced uh four times indicted
ex-president had to count there
it's like they're all ready to pop
they do have that special glow they're
expecting that Trump's legal troubles
will deliver a surprise next year
this handicaps Donald Trump it hurts
Donald Trump this is an elect a general
election challenge for the president
that likely Bold and boldens the
incumbent Joe Biden
these self-proclaimed Defenders of
democracy they want you to believe that
their priority is restoring respect and
dignity to journalism and to politics
it's going to be Justice for All But
when you listen closely you see what
they're really all about they're really
accusing Trump of what they themselves
are just vengeful ideologues who Revel
in the humiliation and shame of others
and everything you're going to be able
to see live on TV they're going to be
mug shots they're going to be
fingerprints Donald Trump will be
fingerprinted he will be photographed
and end up with a mug shot the very
first presidential mug shot
these people are sick
how is a mug shot of the former
president in any way necessary
or in any way good for America
are they really worried that he's going
to disappear into the general population
or that as a 2024 presidential candidate
that he's going to try to leave the
country flee
I have to expect him to push for bail to
be set at a billion dollars that'll show
them
the sick fantasy never ends
Donald Trump will find it very difficult
to even be given bail there's bail that
is the the thing that he is not
factoring in is he continues speaking
the way he has been speaking one if not
more of these judges will take action
I'll take action
of course for years the humiliation
squad has been itching to see not just
that Trump mug shot but also to have him
behind bars
you're saying that a judge could lock
him up a waiting trial we'll be
incremental punishment the first thing
Donald Trump has to do is go to jail
he's now facing jail time in a whole
bunch of different places
now think about how strange and how sad
it is to be a political analyst and what
you're hoping for most is to take an
opposition candidate off the campaign
Trail so no real debate no real campaign
just to be silenced
if not put in actual prison they Ponder
how to stop him from doing more
so-called damage to America
there's this question of how do you
contain Donald Trump Harry she could
also revoke his bail and put him under
house arrest
of course even that's not good enough
for these vipers so the big thinkers
over at Salon describe Trump under house
arrest and Trump being deprived of his
phone as somewhat unsatisfying
but it actually gets worse writer Amanda
Marcotte says frankly it's better for
almost everyone if Trump actually loses
his freedom from these threatening
antics
it's better for almost everyone for
Trump to be in prison not be able to
speak
certainly the 74 million who voted for
Trump in 2020 would beg to differ not
that Salon actually considers those 74
million people to be actual human beings
entitled to their own views
and as usual as part of their act
Democrats always seize the opportunity
to portray Donald Trump's supporters as
potential domestic terrorists the
country shouldn't be directed by them it
should be protected from them
we had an increasing amount of security
outside of the Fulton County Courthouse
the security concerns around the
courthouse and what might happen in
Georgia as this case progresses she's
reached out to the sheriffs for
protection she's notified the judges to
have them keep their staff at home
so what's really going on here
could this be the pretext to justify not
just limits on Trump's own speech but
2024 limits on campaign rallies
campaigning at all or even in-person
voting
those poll workers in Georgia who
received your targets of such hate and
and terrible racism and threats of
violence uh because they were unfairly
maligned uh by Trump and there's real
concerns about elections this time
around violence is always looming on the
horizon especially in this moment if
just a half a percent or even a percent
of that half a percent think that
violence is the answer they're going to
go after these folks this is very scary
what's scary is that their entire reason
for being for living seems to be
singularly focused on seeing Trump
humiliated
and by the way these Fanatics aren't
just giddy because they want to see
Trump shamed in these trials and
everything that will come with the
trials they also firmly believe that
they're putting conservative populism on
trial as well
now we all know and I certainly know as
a former criminal defense attorney that
anything can happen when juries are
involved even in what our obviously
politically motivated prosecutions
but anyone predicting that the pig pile
that we're seeing on Trump predicting
that that's going to lead to the demise
of the America first movement
well that person himself will be
humiliated down the road and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else